hello everyone this game was played in a
Riga in 1949 between the 12-year old mix
hotel and the 15 year-old Joseph Zilber
and it illustrates nicely how already at
such a young age that had the spirit of
a great attacker so let's see the game
Tao is white and silver is black B 4 B 6
d 4 D 5 the French defense 9 2 D to c5 e
takes on d5 Queen takes on d5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 Bishop to c4 Queen to h5
d text on c5 Bishop takes on c5 Knight
to e4 Knight gt7 Bishop to g5 into g4
Queen to d3 b 6 tall castle inside and
the upper castles King side and this is
a critical position of the game in this
position is completely winning for white
in hill in here tau should have just
played well h3 the Jeep on cannot be
taken because Ruby to g1 captures black
screen so as for something like Queen to
a5 g4 and this is crushing for white if
Queen goes to g6 and simply Queen the
night stage for drive to create Queen
and if that wants to avoid this will
have to play something like Knight to e5
and well that will simply capture and
after this exchange tab will be up a
piece so that's what all should have
plays he just feature to play just h3
and the window game and in his book life
in games of mikhail tal he actually
remembers this game and he says that he
doesn't really know how we missed this
but he plays Bishop to f6 and this looks
like a dangerous move because the bishop
can be taken if you captured a bishop
then simply nice to have six force the
Queen in the King but completely missed
blacks next move like just plays Queen
to f4 check and the stripped I'll place
came to be one another Bishop can be
captured so now it's simply down a
bishop but tell us
he wasn't a very you know sad about this
move he said okay I'm down a bishop
let's just continue the game and so he
did he played g3 attacking blacks Queen
Queen to 8 6 g 4 tau pushes the pawn
forward when goes back T 402 F for g5 we
have a test XG 5 night X and G 5
Knight to g6 and now H 4 nice to be for
attacking the Queen Queen to H 3 and in
this position black should play
something like h6 keeping the knife from
the g5 but it would place the point 85
and make this discover the tech on the
Queen on h3 so tell play is going to G 2
and now silver plays Bishop to f5 and
this is enough for towel to win the game
top lace h5 and it's not really good for
this nice to move as White will have all
sorts of discoveries so he plays King to
g7 South captures the knight h6 towel
plays Bishop captures on f7 rook
captures on f7 g g captures on f7 h2
captures on g5 Knight captures on g5 and
Zilber plays Queen captures an f2 and in
this position the 12-year old Tao finds
the fourth checkmate in 8 moves and
usually I'd never ask you to pause the
video and solve the position you see on
the board
but maybe this time you'd like to is
it's not every day you get to Seoul
check for checkmate in eight moves so
feel free to pause the video and ok for
those of you who pause the video and who
have been successful in solving this
position I congratulate you you who made
it all very happy and for those of you
who haven't well this is what Saul had
in mind
Tom plays Knight to e6 check and this is
a double check from the knight and the
Queen
so black plays King captures on f7 top
plays Queen to g7 check and forces the
black King to capture the knight on e6
so King captures on e6
top plays rook to see the route
six check black castor block with the
Bishop of Bishop to g6 only move Queen
captures on g6 check King 37 rook to h7
check King to f8 Queen to g7 check
Kim's to e8 Queen to d7 check came to f8
and not rook the h8 checkmate so a very
nice combination and it a forced
checkmate in Athens by the 12 year old
Michael Tao like I said it's nice it
nicely illustrates how he already had a
spirit of an attacker at such a young
age so once again I congratulate all of
you who were able to solve this and I
hope you enjoyed this game and all see
you soon